yuzu  we're finally here  who the hell are you  looks like trouble yuzu  boss they're here again let's run  boss  it's matilda and hildegard  looks like our adventure is getting  started let's go yuzu  hi everyone do you know me yep my name  is crunchyroll  me and yuzu finally made it to  mitrosphere we're going to go on a quest  to stop those nasty sky pirates from  wreaking havoc on edeltown  let's battle them together and along the  way we have some amazing things planned  for you  there's going to be a new free avatar  and costume set i think you'll love them  as much as i do  also check out our very first step up  gotcha there will be new rainbow  equipment can't wait to use them all  and the best part you'll have a chance  to get yuzu on your team  well it's time to head out we'll see you  there  let's go yuzu